Can I take glutatholium breast cancer in my chiropractor recently tested me and wants to be to take it?
The answer is
It depends really so if you have breast cancer, but you're in full remission and you feel like you've really conquered that
Can you take glutatholium? I would say yeah, I'd say you could probably go back to taking some antioxidants
But if you have breast cancer and you're still dealing with the breast cancer, you would feel like you haven't totally conquered this and you're concerned about growth and you're
dealing with you know, still you're not over it that you shouldn't be taking antioxidants. So
Of course, there's multiple different theories behind this and I've been on both sides of the fence of the fact
But if we're using
So I talked to somebody the other day that
Can't remember who was but they went and did we're doing IV
Vitamin C was somebody who was a clinician who was gonna treat them for their cancer and they were doing IV vitamin C
IV glutatholium and something else that was an antioxidant as well. I can't remember. So they were doing
I'm invited to see remember at the dose that you'd get IV vitamin C anywhere above 10 grams which
Typically you'll be getting that would be a low starting dose of IV vitamin C
If you take vitamin C orally
Typically about 500 to 2000 milligrams a day
That's an antioxidant that's going to have antioxidant effects on you
high dose vitamin C is going to be oxidative. That's why it kills cancer low dose vitamin C is not going to be cancer killing
It will stimulate your immune system. So secondarily it can help
But it's also vitamin C at that dose functions as an antioxidant now
If you if this is new information. I have written a blog post called hearticine
Hearticine oxidative stress to kill cancer. I think the type of the blog post if you go search that out
Cancer cells are reproducing
Cells that are not really healthy because they're rapidly replicating. They're already
Have a higher level of oxidative stress and this is what you're you're betting on when you do chemotherapy
So you're doing chemotherapy. You're taking out a toxin which is an oxidized agent
Which will tip over cancer cells before they'll tip over healthy cells and those cancer cells will die therefore the idea of
Chemotherapy is we're going to give this person enough chemotherapy to kill the cancer but not enough to kill the patient
Meeting that we're going to try to spare as many healthy cells as possible even though we're damaging healthy cells because we're we're giving them this oxidizing agent
Well, interesting enough nutritional oxidizing agents like high dose vitamin C
Don't damage healthy cells. They're not causing an oxidative stress state to a healthy cell
They're only causing an increase oxidative stress state to a cancer cell which is already at a highly you know an elevated
Oxidative stress state or you could say more near its lethal desk dosage of oxidative stress
So you're basically adding a little bit more toxin to that
cancer cell
AKA oxidative stress to that cancer cell that's already near its lethal dose of oxidative stress. They're might kill you the cancer cell
So if you're taking glutathione you are in effect
keeping cancer cells
From dying from oxidative stress because that's that is the very reason why cancer cells
are in an elevated oxidative stress state is because they're mitochondria
Because they're rapidly replicating their mitochondria can't produce enough glutathione
To get rid of the oxidative stress that exists within the cytoplasm of the cancer cell
So when you take glutathione you could have be effectively keeping a cancer cell
alive. You're effectively
Uh, giving CPR to your cancer cells that you're trying to kill
With other measures. So
Most alternative cancer therapies whether you're taking b17 or
SCAC or
medicinal mushrooms or
You know, you go on name it all these cancer therapies that we're doing on you are oxidative
So they're doing the same thing
um
Physiologically as as chemotherapy is doing
Without the negative effects of chemotherapy because chemotherapy doesn't spare healthy cells
Whereas a nutritional approach I mean person is healthy could take layatrol could take b17 and it's not going to cause cancer
But if person's healthy takes chemotherapy they're going to get really super sick. Why because they have all this cell lysis because you're killed your poisoning healthy cells
um, so
You don't want to take antioxidants when you're
When you're trying to kill cancer cells. So
Very long answer. I apologize
For no, I would disagree with your current partner. You know, I get this a lot not to bash other practitioners who are trying very hard to help people, but
To cancer is totally different than everything else
The things that you would do to keep a person from getting cancer
Would be the exact opposite things you would do if you already have a cancer diagnosis the things you would do from cardiac support
You wouldn't do if you had an diagnosis of cancer. So there's some things in the natural
nutritional
Functional medicine atroopathic
etc etc world
That they learn then I've learned that
You have to rethink what you're thinking about
Helping somebody with cancer. It's just it's just different because
So you know, it's just the different disease. So you have to think differently